Republic
this is the French President removing
his luxury watch during an interview
when he's telling the workers of France
that they're just gonna have to
sacrifice a few more years before they
retire and he's doing this while France
is quite literally burning to the ground
city services have shut down from
workers going on strike garbage has been
piling up on the streets for over three
weeks protests have erupted with
Millions joining in protesters even
stormed BlackRock the company that owns
the world while lighting flares all
because the president of France macron
is trying to increase the retirement age
from 62 to 64. many see the fights over
pension as the last 10 defense of
France's social welfare model